Traduttore: Sebastiano Inama
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Buonasera a tutti. Grazie.
Il mese scorso mi trovavo a Londra
a un importante evento
presso l'Open Data Institute.
Quel giorno ho conosciuto la persona
che vedete in mezzo nell'immagine,
Tim Berners-Lee, l'inventore
del web e del WWW (World Wide Web),
una persona che sta parlando
tantissimo di condivisione dei dati.
Una sera ho avuto occasione
di parlare con Tim Berners-Lee,
incontrarlo e confrontarmi con lui.
Gli ho mostrato quest'oggetto,
che ha destato tantissimo
la sua curiosità, così come la mia,
il giorno in cui ho ricevuto
questo regalo, qualche giorno prima.
Questo oggetto è molto particolare,
perché la mappa che vi è sopra
è la mappa di OpenStreetMap.
Una mappa che sta cambiando il mondo.
OpenStreetMap è un progetto
molto simile a Wikipedia,
dove tutte le persone possono contribuire.
Wikipedia è un'enciclopedia,
OpenStreetMap è una raccolta
di dati per creare mappe.
Ognuno può partecipare: partecipo io
e può farlo ogni persona in sala e fuori.
Per spiegarvi meglio quant'è
il contributo di OpenStreetMap
e come questo ha coinvolto
tantissime persone,
voglio usare questo video di ITO World,
che parte adesso.
Il video mostra quattro anni diversi,
e ogni lampo è il contributo di persone
che stanno raccogliendo dati,
dati che contengono coordinate.
Queste coordinate a loro volta
descrivono strade, edifici,
di volta in volta
sono aggiunti degli attributi,
per definire ad esempio che
questa strada è più stretta, più larga,
il limite di velocità,
la tipologia di asfalto.
Vengono anche raccolte informazioni
quali le fontanelle dell'acqua,
anche cose che vengono raccolte
per fare presente che esistono.
Un mio amico ha trovato
un ippodromo abusivo in Sud Italia.
Come vedete, i lampi sono tantissimi,
come anche le persone che contribuiscono.
Abbiamo raggiunto un milione
e duecentomila utenti,
che adesso stanno inserendo
informazioni all'interno della mappa.
Veniamo a Trento: questa
è la mappa come la vedete a Trento.
Sulla mia destra vedete OpenStreetMap,
sulla sinistra vedete quella di Google.
Non sto qua a sindacare
qual è la più importante delle due,
forse una è più leggibile, l'altra meno,
ma sicuramente quella di OSM
è ricca di informazione e tantissimi dati.
E lo potete vedere.
E dovete pensare che ogni informazione
che vedete, quelle rappresentazioni,
sono la generosità di persone
che contribuiscono al progetto.
Ci si domanda: "Chi sono questi mappers,
queste persone che raccolgono dati?"
Questo è Edoardo, che con Simone Cortesi
è stato uno dei pionieri di OpenStreetMap
in Italia.
Durante un 'mapping party',
momenti in cui la comunità si incontra,
raccoglie dati per poi condividerli.
Gli strumenti che vengono usati
sono i più disparati.
Sono strumenti per raccogliere note,
come una macchina fotografica,
un registratore vocale,
che grazie al GPS ottengono
anche le coordinate,
e grazie a un computer o a una foto aerea
è possibile tracciare e ricavare dati.
Tra queste informazioni
ce n'è una che un po' fa ridere.
È uno scontrino fiscale.
Il messaggio che voglio dirvi
è che lo scontrino fiscale
contiene dei dati interessanti
che la comunità OpenStreetMap prende
per arricchire ancora di più la mappa.
Lo scontrino, ad esempio, ha la tipologia
di negozio, numero civico, e via dicendo.
La semplicità con cui questi dati
vengono raccolti e costruiti
permette di fare grandi cose.
Ora mi sposto in Africa,
esattamente a Nairobi, a Kibera,
una bidonville di 170.000 abitanti.
Molto più grande di Trento.
C'è un gruppo di persone
che sta raccogliendo dati lì,
perché è nuovamente
OpenStreetMap contro Google.
Quella più povera è quella di Google:
perché non c'è motivo per far sapere
al mondo che Kibera esiste,
ma la mappa parla da sola,
lo sta dicendo su quella mappa lì.
Vedete quante croci rosse ci sono?
Sono punti di soccorso, in cui
c'è gente che ha bisogno di aiuto.
E il motto di Map Kibera è
"rendere visibile ciò che è invisibile".
Guardate quante informazioni ci sono.
La necessità che hanno
queste persone, anche di coordinarsi.
Infatti sono segnate le latrine, i negozi.
E una cosa che mi affascina tantissimo
sono anche i percorsi che hanno nomi,
perché quelle persone
esistono, 170.000 abitanti,
e devono muoversi
all'interno del loro territorio.
Il progetto poi ha quest'aspetto
umanitario che ha creato un team,
Humanitarian OpenStreeMap Team,
famosissimo durante
il terremoto di Haiti del 2009,
ma attualmente attivissimo.
Nel caso delle Filippine:
al momento ci sono 1.300 persone,
forse di più, ho controllato ieri,
che grazie alle foto aeree aggiornate
riescono a tracciare
le nuove mappe delle Filippine,
perché alcuni edifici non esistono più,
delle strade sono state interrotte,
e queste sono utilissime
ai soccorsi umanitari.
Non serve comunque andare
nelle Filippine, per capire questo,
perché lo sapete benissimo
cosa è successo adesso in Sardegna.
Valentina Murtas si è data da fare
per raccogliere informazioni
su quello che sta accadendo
in questo momento in Sardegna.
Quei puntini rossi che vedete
sono la generosità dei sardi
per venire incontro ad altre persone
che sono in difficoltà,
per offrire punti di raccolta,
dei luoghi di ricovero.
E trovate tutto questo in questa mappa.
Questa mappa però a sua volta
ha bisogno di essere arricchita.
Valentina per due giorni non ha dormito,
tant'è che ieri, l'ho sentita, è svenuta,
per cercare di raccogliere questi dati
e renderli disponibili a tutti.
Ha chiesto aiuto alla comunità
di OpenStreet Map,
perché anche qua
serve la mappa aggiornata,
in modo che i soccorsi possano intervenire
e tutta questa generosità che si sta
mettendo in pratica sia amplificata,
per permettere a chiunque di intervenire.
Scappando dal mondo delle emergenze,
veniamo a una situazione
un po' più vicina all'Italia,
pensiamo ai beni culturali
che ha l'Italia.
Nuovamente, le due mappe a confronto.
Gli scavi di Pompei:
c'è tanta gente nel mondo che guarda
con interesse questo scavo, questo luogo.
Non esiste una mappa che sia riusabile.
Quando dico riusabile
vuol dire la possibilità di avere i dati
che hanno costruito quella mappa
per poterla fare in tanti modi diversi,
perché mettere in evidenza
un'informazione piuttosto che un'altra
mi permette di spiegare meglio
quello che accade
e di rivalutare meglio il territorio.
Queste immagini che vedete sono di Pompei,
è sempre la stessa informazione
rappresentata in maniera diversa,
e addirittura in tre dimensioni.
Chiaramente è una semplificazione,
ed essendo un progetto internazionale
questo vale anche per Trento.
Ed ecco qua Trento, rappresentata in 3D.
E voglio farvi notare che ai giardini
adesso ci sono dei lavori in corso,
e la comunità ha informato di questo,
e la rappresentazione 3D lo riporta.
Poi avendo a disposizione i dati
succedono anche cose un po' più carine.
Questa è ancora Trento,
sempre la stessa identica zona,
con una rappresentazione ad acquarello.
La rappresentazione ad acquarello
forse non potrà servire in casi umanitari,
forse non serve per spiegare meglio
quello che è successo ai beni culturali,
ma un mio amico lo sta usando
per l'etichetta dei suoi vini,
una mia amica ha aperto una cartoleria
e crea la carta personalizzata,
esattamente come la busta in cuoio
che vi ho fatto vedere prima.
Mi sono fatto fare la busta in cuoio
con la mappa del posto dove lavoro.
Adesso mi sposto su una cosa
molto più vicina a me,
su un percorso da Rovereto a Matera.
La comunità si incontra
attraverso una conferenza
che in Italia chiamiamo OSMit,
dopo l'internazionale State of The Map.
Abbiamo organizzato
l'incontro agli inizi di ottobre,
abbiamo fatto questo incontro
anche con la comunità di Wikipedia,
e questa cosa è piaciuta
tantissimo ad altre persone.
Ida, da Potenza è arrivata alle quattro,
aveva l'intervento alle cinque,
la conferenza iniziava
alle dieci del mattino,
semplicemente perché ha chiesto
di ospitare il convegno a Matera,
il prossimo anno, nella Città dei Sassi.
C'è dietro un motivo:
Matera è candidata alla
Città della Cultura Europea 2019.
Per noi della comunità di OpenStreetMap
questo è stato molto interessante,
perché, in un certo senso,
si è visto come un punteggio
per fare in modo che
OpenStreetMap porti cultura.
È quello che sto cercando di dirvi:
cultura che aumenta la qualità della vita,
come nel caso di Kibera.
Il 21 ottobre mi hanno chiesto
di scendere, perché hanno detto:
"Sì, ci piace, ma non siamo così bravi.
Ci puoi aiutare a capire
come funziona OpenStreetMap?"
Sono andato lì, e invece
di un map-party si è fatto un 'mappart',
che è la stessa identica cosa,
però è un gioco di parole
per gli abitanti di Matera
per dire: diamoci una mossa,
diamoci da fare.
Il risultato è questo: nel 2008
la mappa di Matera era così.
Chi mi ha introdotto vi ha detto
che il progetto nasce tra il 2004/2005.
2008, Matera era così.
2009, strada principale.
2010, 2011, 2012, 2013.
Io sono sceso il 21 ottobre.
Il 21 ottobre la mappa si presentava così.
Quattro giorni dopo, era così.
Una settimana dopo così.
Due settimane dopo in questo modo.
La comunità si è data da fare,
si è attivata per rendere la mappa
sempre più importante.
Non è facile disegnare
percorsi ai Sassi di Matera.
Vi rimando con l'immaginazione
alla fotografia di prima: Sassi di Matera
Si è creato un gruppo su OpenStreetMap
che ha iniziato a darsi da fare
su Facebook per iniziare a discutere.
Sono uscite delle cose
molto carine su questo,
perché ad esempio c'è Angelo che dice:
"Che bello, ho inserito la fontana
e sono molto orgoglioso di questo".
Secondo me questo è molto importante:
rivaluto il mio territorio e sono
orgoglioso di quello che sto disegnando.
Piero invece va a dire:
"Guarda, c'è un progetto
interessante legato a OpenStreetMap
che riguarda l'accessibilità -
diamoci da fare su questo".
Discussioni lunghissime
che hanno aumentato
la consapevolezza del territorio,
che hanno portato tante nuove idee,
ed è nato un progetto:
rivalutare gli spazi verdi di Matera
per poterli utilizzare come orti urbani.
Oppure questa strada,
questa "non ferrovia" di Matera,
una ferrovia che
non è mai stata completata.
I cittadini hanno iniziato a ragionare
su come può essere rivista,
e l'importanza di avere una mappa
è stata fondamentale.
Bene, settimana scorsa
mi è arrivato un messaggio
da parte dell'assessore all'innovazione
di Matera, l'assessore Trani,
e mi ha detto che Matera è in finale
come Città della Cultura Europea.
Per me questa cosa è stata molto toccante,
perché sento di avere dato un contributo,
non solo io, ma tutta
la comunità di OpenStreetMap,
perché, ci tengo a dirlo,
in questo momento
tutta la comunità si sta organizzando
per aiutare la Sardegna.
Mi fa molto piacere essere qui
anche perché sono di Trento,
d'altra parte vorrei
essere attaccato al computer,
perché la comunità italiana di OSM
in questo momento si sta organizzando
per migliorare i dati della Sardegna,
e per fare in modo che
la mappa di prima, SardSOS, migliori.
Io concludo così.
Spero di vedere qualche
vostro contributo nella mappa,
di avervi anche convinto
che questo è un grande vantaggio,
che comunque può cambiare
veramente la vita delle persone,
dando degli scenari diversi:
da Kibera, dai problemi di emergenza,
dal fatto di poter dire: "Divento
Capitale della Cultura Europea",
o inventarsi qualche nuovo oggetto
come quello che vi ho mostrato prima.
Grazie.
(Applausi)